hey guys it's februari ninth and you're
watching gamespot news your regular host
just isn't feeling well today so I'm
going to be filling in and with the
overwatch beta patch going live today
she's probably not the only one feeling
a little sick first up the rumors are
true the division open beta is confirmed
and Xbox one players are getting it
first Ubisoft announced today that an
open beta for the division will take
place later this month it begins
februari 18th on xbox one and comes to
ps4 and PC one day later the pre-release
play period which follows a closed
multiplayer last month comes to a close
on all platforms februari 21st Ubisoft
also confirmed that players across all
platforms can preload the beta starting
februari 16th the divisions open beta
will include all the content from the
closed beta as well as in all new story
mission though no further details were
shared about this Ubisoft also said that
everyone who takes part in the beta will
receive a special in-game reward for the
full game when it arrives on march eight
additionally ubisoft released a new
trailer it focuses on the game's enemy
factions including the rikers the
rioters the last man battalion and my
favorite the cleaners led by their
lovable dictator scruffy Clark I turned
a regular bard in Jeb daven bar next up
a fallout 4 patch lands on ps4 and xbox
one today and you can see the difference
fallout 4 s 1 point 3 patch which was
released last week on pc is now out on
ps4 and xbox one among other things this
update dramatically increases object
fading distances the developer said in a
tweet that includes a comparison video
in addition to the object fading upgrade
the patch includes general memory and
stability improvements as well as a
series of bug fixes one bug fixed in
this update involved players warping to
a different location when they were
aiming which sounds just as much of a
pain in the butt as it is it also fixes
a bug where player will become
dismembered while still alive I'm no
doctor but I'm pretty sure that
shouldn't happen
finally is it your birthday today
because square-enix just due to do with
gift yeah it's an app you have to pay
for it that's right you should make your
way to the app store today and download
final fantasy nine because four units
just released it out of nowhere we knew
the 2000 RPG with coming to smartphones
but until today we didn't know when well
it's now you can download it today from
iTunes and Google Play for 17 bucks
which is twenty percent off the original
price you can get that sweet deal until
februari 21st in the game's description
Square Enix warns with file sizes very
large and download will take quite a
while depending on your connection it
weighs in and around four gigs whoa but
Square Enix says it will require eight
gigs to download so start deleting all
those super cute photos and videos of
your family and that brand new puppy who
needs them when you have an
anthropomorphic rat a boy with a monkey
tail and a genderless dude that loves to
eat so that's all I have for you today
hopefully just will be feeling better
tomorrow and she can take back the reins
or maybe the overwatch beta will still
be out
you